hello everyone i am papanta today i am
going to present to you our book about
another cochlear physics from the
combinatorial news generation
this is so good with the multiplicity
christians omar fuzzy and figuring zara
our paper is about constructing special
combinatorial office called the corner
princess
which is motivated by a central problem
in the communication complexity memory
we focus on the multi-party
communication complexity on
number on the forehead model
cognitive princess of which has been
much interested with recent years under
some books of lina petersy and sherman
in itc
2018 and the lina sharma in the ccc
2000
uh
uh twenty one
and
uh viewline cover on the
2019
on the quasi random group and
2021.
in the
work of lina and charman last year they
contracted a lot of the corner pieces
in the intersect by designing
efficient and web communication protocol
in our work we take the different
approach
in the other by using our surprise tool
namely we make the progress by
introducing in this area the mental
coming natural regeneration
in this talk the first i will
present what are
the thesis
and the second i will be then our
resource on the
corner process
then i will present more detail our
motivation in the multi-party
communication complexity
namely will focus on the e-bar function
and finally i could
introduce
a combinator or degeneration
combinator or degeneration method for
contracting
cognitive reset
so what are the copper pieces
a corner is a trip triple of the points
of the form x y x plus lambda y and x y
plus lambda which lambda
is nonzero with lambda equal to zero we
call the trivial coordinate
uh
in this corner we have the iceberg the
center and the and the and the first
coordinate when we turn lamp
from the first pollinate and which end
of the second corner on on the first
point
the corner has been studied on the
various settings
[Music]
into the bridge if we consider aqua in
the greece and
uh
we will consider the iy with operation
on the finite rule
let's see
here is this
example of the
partner in the
three countries in the great three
countries here you can see the here is
the center of the scanner and then first
we can the first one in it we cannot put
one and second we
change the second convenient with lambda
equal to one here is the example of the
corner in the finite group on the finite
or the finite view f3
uh
f3 with this center
and then either this center and within
first corner and the second column
a subset of the bar in the bridge is
cognitively if
it's no three point form a corner
that means it does not contain any the
corner
so this is an example the
the red point here is
the cognitive set in the into the grid
3.3 and the orange point here is
probably set in
f3 and f3
now we denote the rf with the side of
the largest partner free subset in
greece f time s
for example in
a country set in into the grid
here three countries we have the r of
the three equal to five
and in the finite view f3 we have to
have f3 with the three here
so we want to bow
the side of the largest cognitive free
subset in this
various settings
for the introduction the the
the
group in 2007
so that the non-trivial
upper bound for the
discord process for the low bound from
the bright hand construction the behind
boxing constructs
love this success thus does not contain
three poi form
arrest arizona biodieses we can show
that the
low vowel for the
rn
recently the by using the
communication protocol on the number on
the process model the linear instrument
so
improve the low bar for the
end
and
recent
green also input the low bound on the rn
by the
in the tour in the last year
for the
cognitive reset on the grid namely we
focus on the fpm on the final few fpm
for the f
to n
uh there are some work on green and the
lazy mclean they saw that the
non-trivial
upper bound for the
um
uh
last couple of cognition in the f2n
for the low bounce the book by
uh linna petersen strongman
they saw that the
low bound of the r f to n is at least
2 4 x 2 power n minus small n
and by the arrow construction for the
gaussian problem on f3 we can show that
the the size of the
largest
uh
reset on the fbn is at least 6 by
6 power n
i'll work so that therefore the on f3
and
uh the r of f3n is actually 3.39
for n and the on f3 m is at least 7
power n minus small o
and
this improves the two best known low
bound by the
linear
introducing berliner beta c and xiaomi
and by add a construction for the
f3n
so the question here is where the
fpn equals p
power to n minus small n this is still
the open question
uh our motivation from the
problem in the number on the forehead
model
in the multi-party communication
complexity in this model we
consider
the three pillar alice and both exactly
these people keep
or and
and this string and they're going to
communicate to determine
binary function f
uh
in this model
the
follower i can see every the
other data of the other people but he or
her
he or she cannot see
his or her data possible for example bob
can see the data at least and shortly
but he don't know his
data
and they communicated by the blood
starting in this model you can
think that
they can dry the data on this test
and the objective here we want to
determine the most efficient
deterministic protocol for them to
determine the value of function f and
with with the node is by the d3 f
the central function in the
communication complexity calls
e 5000
the function is equal to one if they're
sum equal to zero
here we
the sum is the
sum of the nb string with
uh plus by each coordinates reverse the
sum of the coordinates on the string
on the two player now so that the d2 of
evaluation equal to omega n
but for the three player the d3 of eva
equal to omega n is to the open question
in the work of chandra first and the
return
and
lina pitashi and x
they saw that the larger quantum preset
in the f2n time f2n is equivalent to
efficient nof protocol for the eva
function
namely
if
the largest counter preset is the letter
c power n
on the f to n with the c strictly less
than four then d3 of e5 equals omega m
for our results in terms of the
um communication complexity
which
improves the
uh best
to best known upper bound for the
function on the f3n and f2n compared
with the two best known f
bar on the
uh provo
in the
proper bs4
by um
okay the our method we use here is uh
using the common natural degeneration
method um as our method can describe
afro the first we describe the copper
pieces problem as a hyper graph
the facade is corner corresponding to
an f
and therefore the cognitive reset
equivalent to the independent set in
this cycle graph
and this type of graph has a power
structure
and therefore we finally we propose the
general method for contracting the
rather independent sets in the num in
the power of hyper graph
and
the method for you is a
community or degeneration
okay let me recall the
definition of the hyper graph and
independent number of hypergraph here we
consider the
directed type of graph name
namely we focus on the three uniformly
type of graph with the vertex at b and
each axis
is the
order triple of the
vertices
an individual set
in
f is the subset of vertex v success that
is does not contain
any athletes
any endpoint of s
and the size of the larvae independent
set is for the independent number of the
hydrograph and we denote this by the
alpha p
now for the corner problem
we
contrast the hydrograph as follows
with the vertex set and have a graph
equal to f to n from f to n
and there is
a
corner in f2l
time to n is
equivalent
and the n equivalent to the an axis of
the hyper graph
for example with n equal to one we have
have the v equal to f two times f two
therefore we have the
four vertices and we also have the
four axis
uh because on f2 thumbnail we have the
four
corner
like this
therefore the by the construction we
have the independent set equivalent
corner preset
uh last is the eliminate set in hyper
graph
is a couple of preset in the f2m time
f2n
now if we consider the according in f2
time f2
uh
like this now if we multiply the corner
another cognition f2 times two we will
of same
here we consider the
we multiply by consider the cartesian
product between two problems
so uh if we multiply with triple formula
that means lambda equal to zero we also
obtain the
another corner in the f two two times f
two two
in other
other direction is the coordinate f two
two times x two two we can write as a
product
between the two corners on the product
of the corner with the triple corner
therefore the
our half graph defined on the powder
problem has the power structure that
means
the
graph creates by the
higher by
graph pressed by the corner on the
f2
mn time f2mn is a product of the
graph defined on the f to n and the
product with the graph hypergraph
f to m
before the present the our technique i
will
present
uh the case of the
directed a secret crop
on the directors of secret graph
with f a and the vertices v
then we can construct the an independent
set on the end copy of the a secret
graph as a side at least v power n minus
small o n
the idea is follow
because
a secret graph we consider the agency
measurement of the earth graph
here we put all diagonal on agent
symmetry input one because a circuit
graph therefore by re-labeling we can
the off then the agency matrix of first
graph is upper triangular matrix
now if we take the
n power of the agency matrix
we will this is the agency
uh
m agency message and then this is the
agency matrix of the n power of the
secret graph because we put the old
diagonal to one this is the reason
therefore now if we
consider the sufficient indexes by
uniform and support
string then we can because our machine
is
upper triangular therefore we
own this
in the
on the subset indexed by the uniform
export screen
is identity matrix
and because the any the independent set
when we research
is from the agency
measuring it is the identity therefore
the
the size of the individual set is at
this the size of
uh
uniform three in in n two four the
fourth side only three for n minus small
n
okay for a single
graph we have the topology of logical
ring on
for
the secret graph namely
we can assign each vertex
by
uh into the number success
if we have an
ij then
a i bigger than ij
i joined
for the a is a vertex labeling map
or
this can be equivalent to the the
hd2
vertex labeling
such that they are equal to zero
on the
[Music]
vertex i and a i plus a b j
because i zero if the i j
[Laughter]
is an s by we
picking the map b equal to minus a from
this definition
now we can generalize
this condition further to a hyper graph
now for the 3d formula is the type of
graph
and left s with any subset of vertex set
v
suppose they are the three map e1 when
uv
e1 u2 and u3
such that they are equal to zero for the
overtake on s and they are
strictly
because on zero for the old vertex
in
the v minus s and they are the strictly
big position zero for the old axis
then we can subcontract
an independent set up
on the end copy of the hardwood graph
has the size at least s power
n minus small o
of the n
here is an example if we take the three
a hypogravity for this 0 1 two and the
three at this
like this now if we take the s is the
vertex set zero one two
with the vertex labeling like this we
construct
as in the table
they have they are the equal all on the
vertex s and positive
uh on the
ad set
therefore in this type of graph the
if we take the end copy of this type of
graph
we can construct the independent set of
the size only three power
n minus small o n
the idea for the proving this term
as follows
further each
hyper graph we can construct the agency
sensor for the hypercraft the indeed
similar to the
asymmetry we put all diagonal
uh
a tensor equal to one
but because we put all diagonal tensor
with one then if we touch the
end copy and tensor power of the
of the
agency sensor
this is also the identity of the end
copy of the a
and copy of the hyper graph
now
we repeated the
uh
sensor on the uniform string
edited by the end to ball
uniform string
here is we consider each element in the
set x
then we will
often uh identity sensor because we
obtain the identity centers that means
the size of the
individual sentence at least the science
uniform string contrast from
the
says f with the length n
okay why
uh
we obtain the identity tensor here
suppose that we not they will not obtain
the identity
sensor that means they exist
the three uniform string from s success
they form the
one f in the entropy of half a graph
suppose the twist string is
a 1 a 2 and a n b 1 b 2 and b n c 1 c 2
and c n
now if we apply the vertex labeling on
this
defy
u1 u2 on u3 on the
three string
like this because
there is a
one s between them that means there is a
uh
in the eye
success in the hyper graph therefore the
this is the row here some
the strictly bigger than zero therefore
the sum of them
uh
strictly because they are zero but
because they have the uniform string
so there's a sum of
all of them uh equal to zero we have the
contraction that means there is no s
between the
three uniform string
okay for the
uh cognitive process on the fp
and
the first we construct the hypergraph on
the fp
for the
sp equal to 2
3
two and three because uh now we
from this theorem
we can go to the
contracts the
subsets will find the substance as
advertisement
as like as possible
such that there is a three three map
satisfy the condition
and
verify the
success
s
satisfies the fourth condition can be
the formula as in the linear program
uh so therefore we can we consider the
problem on the f2n and f2n
and with for the f2n we take on the
three copy and you can find the
uh success
with the size 39 by the end of the
linear program and the one copy of the
f3 f3 we can find the
the largest subset if we equal to seven
therefore we have the
low bar for the uh
largest column of preset on the f2 m
and the f3m
okay because we have the uh we can
contract the rather preset on the fm and
the fpn therefore we can improve the
autobio for the communication completely
on the
uh if our function on
okay let me stop here thank you for
listening